If vomited is a side effect of chemo, how bad is it if I can't keep down my supplements?
Well, let's take one step at a time and
And you know vomiting can be a side effect of chemo, but usually people doing chemo even at the worst
would be
Extremely nauseous after chemo for a couple days. Sometimes it doesn't hit them for a couple days after their infusion
And then they're super sick for three or four days and they can't eat anything or they they could eat a little bit
They can take part of their supplements. They can we just work through whatever we can do
Sometimes people don't aren't vomiting at all. So
Sometimes they just have nausea and we have some different herbs and some different homeopaths for nausea if you if that's the case
So one step at a time we just do the best we possibly can
And it's not like it's there's times when I was really shooting super nauseous and I couldn't didn't take any supplements out there
The need anything that there it's just it's going on at a time